Christopher is with us in Denver hi
Christopher how are you hey Dave how are
you today
better than I deserve what's up well I'm
a dental concern here my 24 year old
daughter recently moved out and she got
a job that she starts on Monday in
Hutchison Kansas and I was wondering
she's over $60,000 in debt from medical
bills and things of that nature how can
I help her get on the same page and I am
with the Total Money Makeover have you
talked to her about it I have but she's
very resistant um she really doesn't
know you know a whole lot about how to
handle our finances and she has $60,000
in debt and it's accruing more every day
why why is it occurring more everyday
well she hasn't paid anything since Oh
about four or five years ago uh-huh okay
so what is the debt I mean sixty is it
all medical or what's the deal at mainly
medical bills how much does she owe on
her car she doesn't have one how much
does she owe on her credit cards well if
you smart she didn't get one of those
either
so it's all medical you say you keep
seeing mainly what else is it um this is
just medical bills all right so it is
all medical bills sent not mainly that's
right yeah all right you're right um
what's she going to be making it her new
jobs um all she told me was she's gonna
be making $11 an hour starting Monday
working as a caregiver for the elderly
okay um well you know if you have in
order to guide an adult whether they're
your friend or your kid
they have to want guidance be asking for
guidance and be willing to accept
guidance and right now I'm not hearing
any of that I mean it's why I don't talk
to people here on the air that don't
want help they call me up they want me
to endorse your stupidity I'm not doing
that and so the problem is when it's
somebody you love you kind of have to
stand back and watch them do stupid if
you try to keep them from it they won't
they're going to do it anyway because
they're allowed to be stupid that's a
that's a the privilege of an adult um so
I mean it sounds like this kids a bit
rebellious
she's like busting out and going to
making $11 halfway across the country
from her parents mm-hmm I'm it sounds
like she's up for a bump on the head I'm
afraid she's going to get some more
bumps on the head what was the nature of
the medical bills what happened children
she's had about six kids she's 24 years
old
mm-hmm I think I've touched on something
with that rebellion thing didn't I mommy
so yeah so where are the where's the dad
well that we're not sure of because she
has got many kids from other kids are
from different people I see and we're
all the kids and they're in foster care
okay oh this kid she's a mess that's sad
I'm just trying to help her out that I
don't have you know the the tools myself
to to do that yeah I would just tell her
that the Total Money Makeover she has to
read if when she's ready to turn her
life around you can show her how to do
it but I mean this girl is she's making
a lot of bad decisions obviously and I
just you can't make somebody take care
of themselves and behave and they have
to choose to do that but I would just
pray for her and ask her tell her that
you know when she wants some help with
this stuff that I'm standing here ready
here take this book with you honey and
if you ever want to sit down learn how
to handle money
this will do it but $11 an hour the
behavior patterns you're outlining for
me and $60,000 worth of medical debt and
halfway across the nation from her
family is not a good formula there's
nothing in this it sounds good
I wish I could be more hopeful but the
only thing that's good about all this is
and you've done it and I've done it most
of us have done it anyway we we've done
stupid we know what it looks like and
you get that bump on the head and then
you get the opportunity to turn your
life around
and so hopefully hers will turn around
sooner than later but um you know I
suspect that she has other issues
entering into her money problems more
than we're outlining right now as you
and I discussed this
you